IT'S A LOVE BITE ♪
♪♪♪
>>> THE MOST STIRRING SHOW OF
2020, ABOUT AN ELICIT AFFAIR
BETWEEN A TEACHER AND STUDENT.
AND NOW, A SNEAK PREVIEW OF
SEASON 2 OF "A TEACHER."
>>> HEY, I KNOW THAT CLASS IS
OVER, BUT I WANTED TO TALK TO
YOU ALONE.
I'M STRUGGLING AND NEED EXTRA
HELP TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I CAN'T STOP THINKING ABOUT YOU,
MS. WILLIAMS.
OR SHOULD I CALL YOU NICOLE?
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> I WANTED TO SPEND SOME EXTRA
TIME TOGETHER.
>> YOU THINK YOU CUTE?
>> WELL, I'M MORE MATURE THAN
THE OTHER KIDS.
>> EXCUSE ME, YOUNG MAN.
DID YOU THINK WE WERE GOING TO
[ BLEEP ]?
>> I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU'RE PULLING A C-MINUS IN
MY CLASS.
THAT'S NOT HOT FOR ME.
YOU CAN BARELY READ.
>> I THOUGHT MAYBE WE COULD --
YOU KNOW WHAT, NEVERMIND.
NO, NO, I WANT YOU TO GO AHEAD
AND WALK ME THROUGH IT.
YOU INVITE ME TO YOUR WHAT?
WE HOOK UP IN THE BACK SEAT OF
YOUR BIKE?
>> OR WE COULD GO TO YOUR CAR.
>> NO, WE'RE NOT DOING IT IN MY
CAR.
MY CAR IS NEW.
>> THAT'S COOL.
>> YOU THINK I HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO THROW THIS JOB AWAY FOR YOUR
LIMP ASS LITTLE NEENOR.
CAN'T DO NOTHING FOR ME.
>> I GUESS NOT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS WAS?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS SPECIAL.
>> OH, YOU THOUGHT I WANTED TO
HAVE SEX WITH SOMEONE WHO CAN'T
DO THE SATs?
YOU KEEP CIRCLING THE BUBBLE,
INSTEAD OF FILLING IT IN.
YOU THINK THAT'S SEXY?
>> A LITTLE.
>> MH-HM YOU KNOW WHAT, LET ME
ENJOY MY LUNCH BREAK?
>> MS. WILLIAMS, I CAN'T STOP
THINKING ABOUT YOU.
>> WHY?
I STOP THINKING ABOUT YA'LL THE
MINUTE YOU WALK OUT OF THIS
CLASSROOM.
>> SEE?
YOU'RE SO CONFIDENT.
>> YEAH, I'VE GOT THAT SWAGGER
THAT YOU HAVE WHEN YOU'RE NOT A
PEDOPHILE.
DON'T SEE A LOT OF CONFIDENT
PEDOPHILES, DO YOU?
THAT SWAGGER WHEN YOU HAVE
HEALTH CARE AND A PARKING SPOT.
GOT, I HATE KIDS.
>> YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I LOVE YOUR CLASS.
>> NAME ONE PRESIDENT.
>> UM, HUCKLEBERRY?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> KERMIT?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON IN HERE?
ARE YOU HAVING AN INAPPROPRIATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH A STUDENT?
>> NO, PRINCIPAL MILLER.
GOD, NO.
>> OH, GOOD.
BECAUSE HE'S MY BOYFRIEND, AND
WE'RE IN LOVE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
ARE WOMEN STILL DOING THIS?
>> THEY ARE.
I AM.
>> SO, HOW ARE YOU THE
PRINCIPAL?
>> WELL, THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
YOU SEE, I USED TO BE A PRISON
GUARD WHO LET PRISONERS OUT
BECAUSE I LOVE THEM, AND NOW I
WORK HERE.
>> OKAY, THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
WILL SOMEONE SAY KIDDING, SO I
DON'T HAVE TO DO NO PAPERWORK?
>> KYLER, IT'S YOUR 18th
BIRTHDAY TODAY.
WE CAN FINALLY BE TOGETHER.
>> NAH, THIS JUST ISN'T HOT FOR
ME ANYMORE.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, MR. NEITHER.
>> GREAT.
>> THERE GOES MY LUNCH BREAK.
>> A TEACHER.
>> HAVEN'T WE LEARNED?